President Biden will finally talk about
border security tonight during his
address to the nation it comes amid
fears of a Hamas style terror attack
happening right here on American soil
according to reports some of the100
billion dollar he's requesting from
Congress will go to the US Mexico border
but that money will be split among other
priorities like Israel Ukraine and
Taiwan that comes as more potential
terrorists are slipping past the open
border US Customs confirming that a
fourth Iranian special interest alien
was apprehended this month in Eagle Pass
Texas all right Jesse you know in in the
first 17 days of this fiscal year more
than 108,000 migrants have been
encountered in the Southwest border uh
and they released over 85,000 of them so
if 3ars of the terrorists make it into
our country is this the biggest national
security issue we face don't make make
me do math on live TV
judge it is and I want to know what this
money is going to do at the border
because they're always talking about
these Hightech systems that they can use
and deploy instead of a wall like what
you can't answer surveillance okay so
you just watch them walk across it
doesn't mean anything Dr so what does it
matter if you spend extra money on the
border if an Iranian is still going to
cross and Joe Biden's border patrol is
going to give him a court date in 2029
to show up it doesn't make a damn
difference and you know Shannon the
crazy part is once I get a court date
people argue they're here legally
because they have a court date but I
think the more the more important
question is that the the the state
department today issued an alert for all
Americans uh abroad for potential
terrorist attacks how do we get to the
point where it's the US citizens now who
have to watch their back well at home or
abroad because in fiscal year for last
year ending that was the highest number
ever a record number of people who came
to the border that were encountered who
were on some type of Terror watch list
they were a family member an associate
was those are the ones that we know
about I mean who knows with the Goda
ways we don't know our polling last week
from Fox News when people were asked not
Republicans but Americans were asked
what do you think about the southern
border 48% said it is an emergency
almost half of them another 37% said
that it's a major problem so to do the
math and I keep it simple 85% of
Americans said it's either a major
problem or an emergency so I don't know
how much the president's going to talk
about this tonight I don't know it's a
terrible topic for him he is way upside
down when it comes to his ratings on
handling the Border all right you know
Greg hundred billion dollar 60% going to
Ukraine uh 40% Israel Taiwan and our
border why do we get the crumbs I don't
know it seems like Ukraine's border is
more important you know and then
meanwhile you have the media and I think
it was axio who trying to deny our own
eyeballs like calling the most basic
reporting pointing a camera at the
border and seeing thousands of young men
cross and saying that's fake news
apparently the problem here is they have
their own assumptions that they have
redefined as facts because they're held
hostage in their own bubble it's almost
impossible to fight that because they
can't change their mind they' it's a
sunk cost of their own beliefs and aside
from that you have to you have to it's
sad to say I think they're already here
we saw the sociopaths celebrating a
massacre in all these cities you see
these protests these are people being
radicalized they don't have to come from
another country right that's the issue
and these are not Mexicans or
Venezuelans you know Jessica the the uh
axios report that Greg is talking about
claims that the border is a myth started
by conservatives so then how do you
explain the 1.6 million Goda aways
during the
administration I've never bought into
that kind of talk about it you can
obviously see certain things and we know
that
it's not a myth we can also acknowledge
that things that were build that they
were going to happen like all the
Caravans that were coming over Etc
didn't end up panning out the way that a
lot of people in the Republican Party
told us that they would but you don't
have to say that it's a
myth they're all coming they're all
that's a big Caravan okay well we know
from the midterm election results that
that was a big bomb in terms of
Republican messaging you ran on crime
and Caravans coming showed footage
constantly of it and guess what people
turned out and voted for Democrats
because of it was do it was the do's
decision up next wait I'm not done oh
okay as fun as that was so to Shannon's
point this is an issue that matters a
lot to Americans therefore it should be
addressed and just take the W this is a
lesson that I never understand why you
people don't learn in politics like
Biden now is building hard wall right
like everyone wanted him to do that now
it's happening he says it was a money
that was appropriated has to spend it
Etc take the W on this take the 40 m 40
billion take it on the wall and hope
that there's positive change now I am
done I hope you enjoyed hope and change
hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now